okay so you just got back from Iceland
uh where you saw some geysers
so I am going to tell you about a
sequence that has a lot of geysers in it
it's called the Yellowstone
permutation why it's called the
permutation will emerge in a minute
and in this one you're actually told the
first three terms
and then the rules take over rules are
very simple no term is repeated always
pick the smallest legal number the next
rule says that the gcd the greatest
common divisor of the term you're
putting down there then and the previous
term has to be one in other words the
new number has to be relatively prime to
the previous term but it must have a
common factor with the term two back
let's do it so we're told it begins one
two three now what can we put down for
the fourth term the rule says it has to
be relatively prime to three okay so it
can't be divisible by three but it must
have a common factor with two
well how about four four is the smallest
thing it could be because we have to
always pick the smallest number so we've
got one two and three the smallest
number we could hope to use is four and
four works now we're missing five but we
can't put a five here because five it
even though it's relatively prior to
four doesn't have a common factor with
three
so we can't put a five we need a
multiple of three in fact to have a
common factor with three so six would
work except 6 and 4 have a common factor
of two so we can't put a six
so seven eight nine
nine Works nine and three have a common
factor of three and nine and four are
relatively prime and no smaller number
works so the fifth term is nine okay now
what we have to have a common factor
with four
uh so six is missing but we can't use
six because of the nine nine and six
have a common factor so the next even
number after six is eight and eight
works
and then we keep going like that forever
what comes after eight it's got to have
a common factor with nine so multiple of
three and it can't be six because of the
eight so three six nine it can't be a
twelve because they have twelve and
eight have a factor but fifteen works
okay and what comes next we need an even
number after the eight and we don't have
six yet we can't use six because six and
fifteen have a common factor two four
six eight eight we have we can't use ten
because of the fifteen
um we can't use 12 because of the 15 12
and 15 are both divisible by three so it
can't be twelve could it be fourteen yes
it could so it's a Fourteen and so on
and it goes like that and
it's cool yeah yeah but the interesting
thing is that every so often we get a
big number let me see if we can get to a
big number here is the next few terms
finally we've got we get the five that
we've been waiting for that was the
smallest missing number so I'm glad we
got that and then we can actually fill
in the six and then we get 25
and 12 and 35.
and 16 and 7 and so on and you notice
all of a sudden here we get a number
which is three times as big as n so it
erupted upwards
and if you look at the terms between 100
and 200 you can see that every so often
there's a geyser that erupts just as the
35 jumped up and when that happens
actually they arise because we had a
prime so this jump here is we hit the
prime 61 and then we got twice 61 and
then we got 7 times 61 that was the next
term so it erupted so that's what the
sequence looks like
now in all of these sequences when you
have a rule that says there are no
repeated terms one of the first things
you want to know is does every number
appear eventually and this in this
particular case it's not obvious but
it's true
and I would like to prove it because can
I ask you one more question first yeah
is are the geysers like Old Faithful do
we know how regularly they're going to
go off or are they are they scattered
intermittently like the primes are they
unpredictable no they're they're
predictable in the same sense the primes
are predictable
so not predictable then not predictable
and yet in a way predictable okay all
right rather like the primes popping up
in the string of real numbers do they
does every prime number cause a geyser
or just selected ones yes all primes
cause geezers okay cool yeah well I'm
going to prove that every number appears
and it's I like this proof a lot because
it's slightly clever it's not all due to
me it's a this was a collaborative work
it was uh we ended up writing a six
author paper about this it but the proof
is really lovely and slick and what I
like about it it doesn't use any
high-powered mathematics it's just you
could do it in your head you could do it
with your eyes closed
um there's no need to do any integration
and so on no differentiation no measure
Theory no probability Theory you it just
works so the proof that every number
appears that's why it's called a
permutation because when I've convinced
you of the proof you will know that this
sequence of numbers is the same as the
sequence above it it's the sequence of
integers but rearranged every number
appears okay one step number one is
first of all the sequence is infinite
because you might think after a while we
run out of numbers but in fact there's
always a candidate we could pick some
giant Prime that hasn't appeared yet
call it q and take 15 times Q that's
definitely going to be relatively prime
to the previous term and certainly it
has a common factor with the two back so
there's always a candidate so the
sequence is infinite now the next thing
I need is that some numbers might be
missing and some numbers will be present
and right now we don't know
so let me Define this this is really a
subtle point but it's very a very key
step I want to know when does a number
appear when does eight appear well it
appears as a sixth term so let me Define
w for when w of M is when M appears W of
8 is 6 W 15 is 7 and so on but suppose
101 is missing then we Define w of M to
be minus one if m is missing and I want
to Define l of M
to be the max
the maximum of w of 1 up to W of M the
point is that by the time we've gone out
to W of M every number that appears in
the sequence has appeared this is the
maximum you have to go out to find M you
might and might not be there but if it
is if it is so we take the maximum of w
for all the numbers up to M that's L
stands for last L is the last chance L
of M is the last chance you have to see
an M once you've gone out before Beyond
L of M you're in the outback there are
no more M's
so for n bigger than L of M A of n is
bigger than m
somebody knows so that's how far we have
to go out there
now we can actually do some reasoning I
claim there are infinitely many crimes
that divide the terms of the sequence
proof suppose not suppose Prime p on all
primes are missing and then from then on
all the terms are products of primes
less than P so I want to look at L of P
Squared okay I'm going to go out a long
way in the sequence beyond that point we
know every number is at least P Squared
so a of n is bigger than P Squared we
don't know what it is but we know it's
pretty big and this argument about it
being pretty big is the key step that's
that's the key step number two that it
says the sequence keeps growing so go
out beyond the last Prime less than P
Squared and look at what we have so we
get a term a of N and we know it's
bigger than P Squared we we don't know
what the number before it is or the
number two back but we know there was a
term before for it that had a common
factor with it
as by the definition of the sequence
and so that the linking term the gcd is
a prime less than p
because from now on there are no other
primes so the gcd here is say equal to Q
say and we know Q is less than P because
all the terms in the sequence then on a
product so primes less than P so that
means that QP is less than P Squared Q
is less than p q times p is less than P
Squared but then because this Q is less
than P we could have used Q times P here
instead of P Squared and this is a
contradiction to the fact that we always
take the smallest candidate
so
by assuming that there was some limit to
the primes that appear we get a
contradiction therefore there are
infinitely many Primes
Brady now let me move on to the next
step now we know there are infinitely
many primes in the sequence all right
all right can now prove that every Prime
divides some term let's say 17 never
divides any term then I say 19 can't
divide any term either because the first
time you saw a term that was divisible
by 19 you could have used 17 instead
17 didn't appear if 17 didn't doesn't
appear you can't have a 19 because
whenever you got to a term that had a 19
in it you could have used the 17 instead
if 17 doesn't appear 19 doesn't appear
23 101 none of the primes bigger than 17
appear so that means the only primes in
it are 2 3 5 7 11 13 and 17. but we know
there are infinitely many primes in the
sequence that was step three so we have
a contradiction okay so every Prime
divides some term I just want to remind
you you said you could do this with your
eyes closed yeah I can I can I can
easily do it with my eyes closed it's
easier with my eyes closed really okay
um because I can then
um correct myself without making a fuss
about it all right five
yes any Prime P divides infinitely many
terms step four set every Prime divides
some term so we know that 17 appears at
least once step five says each prime
appears infinitely many times and the
proof is actually rather tricky but what
you do is you say suppose not here are
the terms that divisible by P
there are only finitely many of them
that's what we're trying to prove can't
happen I suppose it's true pick a power
of P which is bigger than all of them I
will prove that's in the sequence
because pick a prime we know there are
infinitely many primes pick a prime Q
bigger than P times 10 to the sixth we
know that Q appears in the sequence
there will come a time when Q will be in
the sequence every Prime is going to
appear eventually well when it appears
we could have used P to the million
instead so that's a contradiction
therefore every poem divides infinitely
many terms we have two steps to go every
Prime appears naked I.E air then equals
P not multiplied by anything for some n
we say suppose it's not true and find a
giant we know the infinitely many
multiples of P so pick a huge multiple
of P
so let's call it h times P
huge multiple of P suppose find a of k
equal to a huge multiple of P then a of
K plus 2 is going to be p
once we've got a huge multiple of P
there's nothing to stop us taking P
itself here
it's the same argument and it's very
simple so okay we're ready for the last
step every number appears in the
sequence
so take suppose K is missing small
dismissing number and we know K isn't a
prime because we know every Prime
appears so let P be a prime dividing k a
prime factor of K and go out a long way
same argument go out a long way until we
get H times a huge multiple of P we know
we can do that by going out far enough
so what's to stop us putting a k here
two steps along the only thing could
stop us if this term here
had a common factor with K itself so
we're okay we're safe unless this also
has a common factor with K but then why
couldn't we put a k another step on
because this has a common factor with K
so the only thing that could stop us is
that this term had a common factor with
K if we're going to block once we get to
a huge multiple of P every term after it
has to have a common factor with k
and if it as soon as it stops having a
common factor with k then the next term
we can put K so we get to block K every
term after this has to have a common
factor with K but that's impossible
because we know if we go out far enough
we're going to come to some primes naked
primes there are infinitely many naked
primes so there's going to be a
humongous Prime sitting here which is
not does not have a common factor with k
so because of Step six
that can't happen qedi and proof so
every number appears that's why it's
called the Yellowstone permutation
this is a graph of the sequence and I
want to put in just as a reference this
is the line Y equals X this is not part
of the sequence it's just a marker and I
put down a DOT for every term and the
dots fall on lines and what happens is
that all the Primes appear very close to
the line of slope one half but most of
the numbers the non-primes LIE close to
the diagonal line most of the time the
nth term is about n the primes are
exceptions and certain odd multiples of
the primes are exceptions some numbers
that are three times a prime appear on a
different line Jesus
yes exactly the geezers there are three
times P three times Prime geysers there
are five times
geysers sorry did I say Giza we used to
you can say Geezer or guys the people
people use both oh good all right yeah
because we used to have a hot water tank
when we lived in the Isle of Wight that
was called a geezer
but in this country the people say
geyser so I will try to say geyser as
distinguished from Giza because Giza
will appear in a different video an old
geezer okay so the the graph of the
sequence the primes are special and they
appear on a line of slope a half almost
all the other numbers appear either
on a line just above the diagonal or on
the line just below the diagonal very
close
if you want to know to be precise about
it there's a line whose equation is
roughly x times 1 minus one over two log
X it's almost the diagonal Y equals X
but there's a slight droopiness to it
all the even numbers appear on this line
and all the odd composite numbers almost
all appear on a line just above it which
is y equals roughly x one plus one over
long there's no two in it this times
rough plus dot dot dot roughly speaking
and then there are the geysers and the
geysers some of the numbers that are
three times primes appear on this line
which is slope three over two some of
the numbers that are five times primes
appear on this line which has slope five
over two numbers seven times the prime
and the slope is seven over two and then
eleven over two and so on they're the
sizes how big can the geysers be can
they arbitrarily High yeah
they come they become more and more rare
but you if you go out far enough you
will see a very large geyser this is a
description of what we see when we look
at the sequence we don't actually have a
proof that this is correct but we do
have a theory that explains everything
and I would just like to end up by
showing you this Theory the theory is
actually wonderful if you study the
sequence you find that most of the time
the numbers go even odd even odd even
odd and so on they alternate in parity
the first 212 steps are a little special
but from Step
213 on we get a group of five terms at
213 we get a disruption twice 101 101 as
you know is a is a prime we get uh 275
which is some random odd number then we
get the prime itself 101 then we get
some random even number which is turns
out to be 198 and then we get at 505
which is 5 times 101. it's five times
this Prime and it's the the geyser
so this is the group of five terms that
disrupted the progression of even and
odd and using that we're able to say all
the even numbers appear on the line Y is
x times 1 minus 1 over twice log X
look I don't think anyone's ever going
to reach new Sloan's level of sequence
expertise but if you want to lift your
game on any area of mathematics or
science including sequences then you
really need to check out today's episode
sponsor brilliant they're online lessons
and courses are elegantly and lovingly
designed you aren't just a spectator
there are quizzes and questions and
interactive elements like this
get smarter get thinking train your
brain brilliant makes learning so much
fun you're gonna wish you started this
years ago and get 20 off Brilliance
premium subscription at brilliant.org
number file
there it is on the screen and I'll put a
link in the video description too
check it out now your brain will thank
you later
[Music]
foreign